the problem is 90% of people are sitting
on 50/50 their whole [ __ ] life which
means their zero zero so when you're
50/50 you get one day and anything else
is you're just [ __ ] sitting and
bullshitting so [ __ ] flip a coin to
pick the one never look back
anybody out there
[Music]
I have a big life decision to make
between two choices how do I know which
way to go
we'll never know what the alternative
would have been
you pick one and you never ever ever
even consider to look back
what should they do which one should I
do
so what should we do Gary wishing people
dibs until you go through it you won't
know I always play this out let's say
when you go to heaven they can show you
what would have happened because that's
the only way you'd ever see let's just
say what people don't understand it oh
you need the wrong call you should have
went to grad school instead of that
opportunity we're in this company
instead of that company but you'll never
believe it you should have went to
vaynermedia and it was perfect and you
rose like a phoenix and you were the
head of all sound and everything went
great but then you had to go to Virginia
on business and you got hit by a car and
you died a31 that's life
[Music]
I passed on uber as an investor twice in
the beginning if I did my normal
twenty-five fifty thousand dollar check
I would have made four hundred million
dollars which means I might have went to
China for a keynote two years ago which
means I could have got hit by a [ __ ]
bus I really believe in that [ __ ] you
just don't know you think you know but
that is not how life works
so to like look at to ideas and think
you can practically make a good decision
is laughable
[Music]
literally flip a coin just pick the one
that feels better right that second and
make it about you because usually what
kids struggle with is the decision they
want to do versus the decision that they
think they're supposed to do based on
the other voices you know I think
anybody who's listening right now if you
want to set yourself up for success ask
yourself how much risk you've taken in
the first 10 15 20 30 40 years of your
life you're gonna figure it out by
tasting it should I eat this cherry will
I like it if the right strategy is to
[ __ ] eat the cherry right moving is
important because you can change the
course you can't overthink it upfront
right like you just can like we're
always wrong a lot of people make the
wrong decision you know no matter what I
say to your question right now and
they're scared they'll continue to be
they won't do they won't put in the work
or they'll be fearful or whatever maybe
and they'll lose I mean a lot of people
lose a lot a lot a lot a lot of people
lose the way to really eliminate fear is
by not giving a [ __ ] about anybody's
opinion my losses are mine I'll deal
with them myself
I don't need your two cents you're
losing plenty on your own if you don't
give a [ __ ] about what people think you
can do everything but the quicker you
start the quicker you do I think people
dwell
I think dwelling is
the wrong strategy I don't even respect
my losses I don't even give them the
time to teach me anything I [ __ ] look
them in the face let's go [ __ ] you and I
keep going think one time for one hour
make a decision and come I don't want to
hear you [ __ ] complaining about it
every day and I mean that way too many
of you dwell on your losses it's holding
you back too many people make a decision
and I cry about their decision every
[ __ ] second you made a [ __ ]
decision own it live it sleep in that
bed shit's over
you lost move the [ __ ] on guys the only
thing I'm hedging against is regret
that's what you need to be careful of
regret scary
[Music]
regret and that's what most people do
they build a life that leads to regret
nobody old and about to die talks about
what they did they talk about what they
didn't do and you're in the best spot
right now you're in the best spot you'll
ever be straight up this is the time to
be most soft
thoughtful but everybody wants you to
figure out your life now your parents
don't have their lives figured out this
is the time to taste and put yourself in
good positions you can do everything
wrong for the next ten years of your
life and be young as [ __ ] and have
unlimited time to do anything you want
thank you Gary now I know which way to
go
[Music]
by the way it was tail
[Music]